street fighter 5 is officially out no as
of today really on PC you wouldn't know
it at home but yeah like I said that's
you know it's been iterated on for years
super street fighter arcade edition that
2012 updates and all that madness and
but this is the first time this is the
latest i guess numbered version it is
the fifth street fighter game and you
have a review progress up on the site
it's correct with good reason it seems
like you've held back on giving a final
score and a final assessment of us speak
to that first of all why why did we not
and when will we see the final review up
there's a couple of reasons primarily
the the game doesn't really have that
much single-player content mmm so you
know if you're the type of person who
doesn't have a friend right next to you
you don't really have a lot to do except
train and maybe go through survival mode
the other option is playing online the
servers were really sporadic and fickle
before launch really and capcom was
telling us oh no this is part of the
process we're getting ready for launch
right what you're experiencing now won't
happen anymore so I couldn't really
review the game because I couldn't say
whether or not online worked I didn't
actually have the real experience that a
consumer would have and here we are on
launch day thank God we didn't put up a
review because servers are still having
issues yeah so it happens every once in
a while helping with them halo
anniversary edition I remember a couple
years back with Chris I played some I
tried to place on last night had a bunch
of connectivity issues and let's talk
about one thing actually first of all
over the weekend and daigo slaves had a
bit of a fiasco yeah he played we have
one dad joke right part of Capcom's I
guys publicity for the game and I go
played lupe fiasco and showed Angeles
and the road actually yeah actually I
don't know I think it worked out for in
Capcom's favor but it definitely started
more on Twitter you know Lupe started to
just he it wasn't for this necessarily
he just was tweeting and facebooking
about how you know he plays a lot of
street fighter he grew up playing street
fighter loves third strike and you know
I think a madcatz representative who
mark man who no longer isn't there
anymore but anyways date he he got
get the match right and so now last
night they played last night Lupe die go
Lupe 132 somehow I I'm sure because
three fighter 5 is a game where
enthusiastic casuals can come in and
stand toe-to-toe with the pros right
well hey I mean that's the marketing he
did he did look okay he did look like a
Tom Riker keeps beating Jason a striker
anybody's like all the time so sometimes
when you can't did he give him the game
yes you're sure yeah you can tell cuz
like Lupe did a lot of wake up dragon
punches and most pro players will catch
on to that let you do that punish you
severely you let him get away with that
a good amount of time like a fair amount
of times and that's kind of a sign of
like yeah he's kind of he's not blocking
all the time why not but I will say to
Lupe his credit he's it's not like he
doesn't know exactly was like he's not
look good you look pretty good like he
had minimal training scrub coming in
yeah he he only got 45 minutes or so to
play to train a little bit with Rambo
fein and you know he see you saw it
right there he just drag playing and so
you know he did pretty well but at the
same time you know like dico started to
try to parry a lot of things like
instinctively he hasn't you know played
as much you know against someone like
lupe where he might just throw something
out so he doesn't have all the parry
timing sounds but you could see you so
just to get one game maybe he's thrown
those Perry's like you know with the
incorrect timing just to make it look
like are we gonna see a rematch at evo
then um who knows well they keep the
stretched out who knows I match mine the
rematch always makes more money in the
first of all someone yeah I guess so
everyone was daigo is gonna be there so
it's up to them as they wanna do the
rumba ebay wasn't the grammys better
things to be doing anyway let's get back
onto the the review obviously like the
community with street fighters super
important thing loads of people tune in
and watch that last night and also on
the steam I guess reviews at the moment
the community are really letting Capcom
how about it especially in terms of the
networking stuff what's up in networking
problems did you have was it just like
servers weren't weren't up consistently
I would lie would turn on my playstation
4 go on a PC and it would tell me how
you need to make a fighter ID and it was
like what about the last five that I
made right yeah gimme a cup just wiping
the server so I have
no sense of like ownership of a fighter
and progressing and earning experience
and all that and like and how that feels
but but even so like it's the the game
is pretty anemic right now yeah there's
not a lot too and i've heard on the pc
version i need to actually test this
today that you can't change the button
configuration so it actually will pre
set it to a keyboard or if you plug in a
joystick you know has to be a direct x
supported joystick right x directory or
what were the work at all it simply
write it doesn't do direct input
controllers so something that is
licensed by microsoft and fits within
their sort of like Ron yeah yeah it will
automatically bind to that that sounds
crazy where people who spent like
hundreds on off Microsoft you know
off-brand choice I think I know most of
those brands will work anything that'll
work on like an Xbox for example when
you're fine because that shares that X
input library like I'm not too good at
fighting games but I always go into the
single-player stuff when I do them my
love's true that a foreign played
through that with a bunch of characters
and the single-player stuff in this is
so sparse like the the main campaign
stuff I've done all that much off that
seemed pretty small the challenges
section as well man I mean like you i
was like i'm not good at fighting games
but i was braising through these you
talking about the survival sorry
survived challenges are not a challenge
i was oh really and challenges will be
the thing that people play to have fun
with the game and become a better
fighter right you know and it's where
capcom can provide tutorials for
specific characters saying like this is
why this dragon punch is so and so or
this that's why you know this this V
trigger is more special like they'll
they'll inform people how to play the
game and in doing that provide them a
way to connect with it not just become a
better competitor but actually feel like
you're you're playing a game and growing
you know over time when right now it's
like okay you can train locally you can
play the super easy single-player
content that is there or you can jump
online where you faced the same concern
everyone's always faced with online
fighting games where's you're going to
go on you're gonna get your butt kicked
you're not going to learn anything and
you're ghetto embarrassed and that's a
really easy way to grow distant from a
game mmm you know if all you have is
playing against the cpu and playing as
someone who's going to destroy you for
the most part what you know what's left
yeah sota seems like they're on both
ends of the difficulty spectrum there as
well and i had a weird situation
yesterday sorry I wasn't wasn't was
survivor mode right that's I'm so that's
the one against the AI right yeah that's
the one where you go for like ten rounds
a 30-year 100 and you play like
different people who jump in is that the
one with you I wonder if that's because
I played one where I basically like
fought somebody for one round yeah then
it asked me that I want to take a
supplement right next one that survival
me that thing yeah so I did that and I
killed the last boss of that section I
think and the game like I guess it was
trying to like registered i donít on the
network and it [ __ ] crashed back to
the menu so I was like what I just
killed all these do and then boom it's
it's worse than the scenario you paint
it's not I mean it's still bad it's not
that the game is trying to at the end
connect to the server and say something
when you have the sort of fight request
stuff turned on or you're just connected
to capcom fighters now yeah and you're
playing survival mode if there's a
problem with the server at any point it
will kick you out really I got to fight
like 26 out of 30 over the weekend the
server down sorry back to the main menu
you lost all that progress and have
nothing to show for it yeah furthermore
if you're playing offline because you're
trying to avoid that sort of thing you
don't earn fight money hello your kid I
bunny is yangtze you can only earn fight
money when you do things while you're
connected to the Internet can I spend
money on find money you can buy is any
way which is the real money currency
equivalent of fight mode got it and for
that you can spend six bucks to unlock
new characters and they come out oh
that's a nightmare what's interesting is
like I find the way fight money is
distributed to be very uneven story mode
incredibly easy yeah I got through it
doing the same command just to see how
easy it was the same action the entire
thing took less than an hour what did
you do a pressing forward and hard kick
alright just repeatedly never did
anything different and I got through it
there's no difficulty setting right
absolutely no difficulty setting um Wow
and so the problem is you beat that and
you get a hundred thousand fight money
and you're like cool it's got a [ __ ]
fat wad of cash yeah meanwhile you go
online right and you struggle for three
rounds you come out on top you're like
man that was that was really hard that
was a real test of my skill yeah 55
money on your way why I want you to get
that a winner loss as a win you don't
get any for a loss a hundred thousand
for 750 full of thousands all this like
every character every every character
but every single character can be
completed total mm-hmm
everything in less than an hour yeah cuz
there's just four fights right not for
everybody I mean what is easy to write
one of them is to Fang looks shows three
chapters the first two are the only ones
that are actual fights the third part is
just a storytelling campaign the first
two fights it for Fang are both against
m.bison oh wait watch both gay both okay
does he change is I did a schism baby
doesn't matter I don't know cousin to
Omega bison who carries it doesn't it's
so easy it doesn't make any difference
it is throwaway content and they try to
provide these backstories for these
characters an entertaining way it's like
kind of light-hearted in goofy like
where some of these characters put their
priorities right art that's used to
present these stories don't look so
rough it is so poor knowing what bengis
the artist behind it had done in the
past like I'm not allowed to say that I
know that he rushed it yeah give me a
break this stuff is not the work of an
artist who sat down to render something
completely there is stuff that is worse
than a storyboard sketch hmm it doesn't
make sense and you said in your review
in progress and it was exactly what I
experienced last night was that some of
the stuff looks like some look looks
unfinished like some of the frames look
like way worse than the next one there's
no consistency in quality island no it's
like it's not that important on its own
and people might say we're nitpicking
but it sort of speaks to this it's a
little package just feels like it's not
really that yeah the attitude behind
this game is exemplified in something
like those images yeah because for as
much as Capcom is saying that they want
to make this and you know a clean slate
bring everyone else in there releasing
this at a time so they can hit all the
tournament's so people who are fighting
in them have access to the game they're
leaving out modes that are for single
player you know or just for the more
casual audience which is the majority of
the audience yeah and then when they do
go the extra mile to give them something
they don't even finish the lab yeah it
it's really unfortunate because the
gameplay itself is really freaking good
I love all the systems that they took
away from you know they took out of four
and all the stuff they replaced it with
like it feels great again like all these
old characters it seems so familiar
they're actually like different and I
want to play old characters and I never
cared about before now because of how
different they are so playing it is
really fun and what I'm seeing Nexus
someone it's
great when I'm waiting for matches
online and it just takes so long to
connect and then I get disconnected and
then I'm just back in the main menu by
myself in my living room it's like you
know I don't I'm gonna play something
else there's nothing for me to do here
unless I want to fight against a cpu
dummy ad nauseam or do the survival mode
stuff and not earn anything for my
efforts because I'm not online it sounds
like a nightmare became to Train review
because like you're saying people
playing next to each other like the desk
beside me he's had Richard Julio plane
yeah a bunch in fact are going to be
doing a stream up street fighter 5 right
after at the lobby so make sure you
stick around but yeah like there's been
people really really enjoying this game
in the office but then when you get
online it's like a chalk and cheese kind
of sit did say it's completely different
what's been your experience of it Eric
have you enjoyed it have you played any
online mostly been local I haven't
played online stuff I kind of started
seeing the tweets and stuff last night
like I can't login I can't do this and
that so I've been playing the office
because we've had it early which is you
know lucky for us of course again but uh
like like Peter said I enjoy it I think
they've done a lot they've made a lot of
good strides in terms of the systems and
the mechanics that they've changed and
you know selected on and also again just
picking making characters that were old
kind of feel fresh and different and
even someone like me that plays can he
plays totally different I don't even
know if I like as normal as any more I
might pick someone else he's got the
worst V skill in the game by the way
what's his one you got it you got a UH
we just got to learn how to use it right
yeah he's the run skill it's a run so
yes Gordon has a kick at the end okay no
no you can do other things that you can
run canceled and stuff oh you can so its
mind game okay I could see that being
yeah but but it's like immediately yes
I'm paper yeah but but kind of harkin on
the point yeah maybe at the game showed
us what he could do with that brazil
yeah it's super important in street
fighter four shipped with a lot of this
stuff it's just yes as a beginner i felt
straight fed her for actually had my
back yeah there's like these new
training mode is kind of off season it
is so obvious how much is missing for
this game because of the timing
association its release alright and that
is really unfortunate because I I want
this game to succeed and at this point I
think it will like I think it will catch
up I you know I want more characters and
a lot of competitors don't necessarily
like a bigger roster yeah like I
understand why because it
it makes it harder for you to understand
all the matchups but it also dilute the
you know who's special and for what
reasons but at the same time it also
provides more variety for people who
maybe they're bored with one character
right they're not hardcore competitors
they want to play this other person but
even for competitors it gives them more
challenges too yeah so they need that
they need the story mode that provides a
better representation of the world and
these characters because let's be on a
street fighter is a series has been
around for a long time it's earned a
incredibly valuable legacy and it's and
it hasn't handled properly so if it can
do that it really can be substantial and
feel special but it's going to take
months and i don't know i think charging
60 bucks is too bad a lot of people on
pc were able to pick it up for like
thirty percent off yeah like there were
three summers daiquiri yeah there's your
dollar companies with their yeah what
they're cheaper pc oh yeah or whatever
but um I that stuff's coming in june
though right i mean not that i want to
give them fast that leg and kind of
sucks that you don't get a day one but
at least it's i guess coming this like
better story to i believe right yeah
it's supposed to be like a like really
an hour to cinematics you know so 3d and
engine stuff from some of the things i
watched during like a preview event
while back they had a short trailer it
was fine it looks good but but really
it's the it's the secondary activities
it's the challenges the trials like all
that stuff that really lets you
interface with in a game with the game
in a different way but dude there's not
even in arcade mode where you can assume
you know so that's immediately what I go
for as well and I was like I spent it
was like I remember the only other time
I felt this way it was when i bought
battlefield vietnam and it said it was a
campaign in the back of the box and then
there was no campaign i spent like five
minutes on the menus be like where the
[ __ ] is arcade mode you can't even play
versus mode against cpu yeah yeah you
know like these are basic things that
have been in fighting games forever
which don't seem like they take all
about anymore it's not survival mode
yeah if it's got survival mode why not
tweak that a little bit and make it our
cade mode like it's it's not that
difficult it really isn't and i don't
know if they thought that like survival
mode to be a good replacement but like
you said it's super easy you can buy
these supplements by trading in points
there's no challenge yeah it doesn't
feel fulfilling now we're like i never
needed a supplement ya know exactly can
you don't even need yeah and i'm not
good at these games
but like men remember the arcade melons
were like okay the first fight was easy
second but yeah but harder and it keeps
for having up and then you get to a boss
or you're just like dan [ __ ] Seth
yeah exactly I street fighter is it
lacks like the spirit that so many
people attach themselves to yeah the
competitors have what they want but
mainstream is not it's weird hey when do
you think you're gonna post a review was
a real tough when it sounds like in one
it's it does so much so writing in this
way but the same game for two different
people who play it for different reasons
is like a completely different
experience right yeah I mean for me I'm
ready to sort of give my opinion on all
that but what I need to do is actually
give the the game a couple days yeah to
play on the servers because I've been
able to get online today I've also been
booted today you know if if it can
become stable by tomorrow let's say
that'd be great that'd be really good to
know because I don't want to publish a
review one day saying the servers suck
and then capcom was like hey we figured
it out yeah at the same time i need to
also test the netcode when it's at its
best because street fighter 5 uses a
feature called rollback I forget exactly
how it works technically but essentially
it'll go back in time after missing some
some frames you know and with low ping
and that can create some really dramatic
problems when you're fighting at least
it did for me like a lot of the
teleporting around the screen to where I
was just hoping I knew where I was going
to be at a right at the right moment
when it caught up to the past and like
yeah it doesn't work so I need to make
sure that you know that stuff is
optimized as well so I think definitely
by Saturday morning hopefully by Friday
cool have my full review of all right
thanks so much lot of people in the
twitch chat talking about the problems
they've had with connecting as some
other people have sort of had better
issues mundus 6 says I've been playing
all day today and last night perfectly
every one of my friends who plays on PC
hasn't had any problems all that play on
pc ps4 are though they can't play and i
had problems on pc last night efforts
and people have got yeah i think if
you're lucky you're lucky it's like if
you got in your lucky you know like
sometimes it works out for some people
sometimes it doesn't so for sure yeah so
we're gonna attempt to do is dream of
this in a couple of minutes i'm about
after lobby so make sure you stay tuned
here founder twitch channel it'll be
happening immediately afterwards if you
are watching on gamespot i would imagine
you have to go back to the homepage
on the NAPLAN link I'm pretty sure oh I
said I'll be the case